what will you call a competition of
hiccups
a hiccup one fine day
nora was about to start her meal her
mother had cooked her favorite dishes
she was very excited and thrilled to eat
all of them
in excitement she started eating really
fast
but while she was eating she started
hiccuping all of a sudden
these hiccups made it difficult for her
to enjoy her meal
poor nora her excitement was killed by
the hiccups
we all experienced this once in a while
but have you ever wondered
what causes hiccups let's find out the
answer
in this video
[Music]
to understand what causes hiccups we
need to understand an important part
inside our body
called the diaphragm it's a dome-shaped
sheet of muscle
that separates our lungs from our
stomach
it plays a very important role in the
breathing process
when we breathe in the diaphragm
contracts and flattens
and our lungs expand this contraction
creates a vacuum which pulls air into
the lungs
and when we breathe out the diaphragm
relaxes
and returns to its dome-like shape due
to which
the air is forced out of the lungs
but how is this related to hiccups
hiccups are caused due to the sudden
contraction of the diaphragm
followed immediately by the sudden
closure of the vocal cords
let's understand this normally
when we breathe in our vocal cords open
up to allow the air to flow into our
windpipe
and lungs this inflow of air
is aided by the contraction of the
diaphragm
but sometimes our diaphragm gets
irritated
and undergoes sudden involuntary
contractions
these sudden contractions cause us to
take a quick breath of air
now this is followed by a rapid closure
of our vocal cords
this prevents the over inflation of the
lungs
and this sudden closing of the vocal
cords creates the hick
sound which we call hiccups
but water rotates the diaphragm in the
first place
the irritation of the diaphragm is
caused by an expansion of the stomach
many things may cause the stomach to
expand such as
eating too much or too quickly drinking
carbonated beverages
swallowing air while chewing gum or
sucking on candy
and so on that is the stomach which lies
right below the diaphragm
becomes bloated and it in turn
irritates the diaphragm which causes it
to contract abruptly
thereby leading to hiccups but
is this the only reason for the hiccups
not really sometimes intense emotions
are also known to cause hiccups
the contraction and relaxation of the
diaphragm
are controlled by the nerve signals sent
from the brain
via the spinal cord intense
emotions like laughing sobbing anxiety
and excitement
can sometimes disrupt the normal flow of
these signals
this in turn causes sudden contractions
in the diaphragm
and these sudden contractions then lead
to hiccups
so these were the probable causes and
how do we ward off this
annoying thing most of the time hiccups
can go on its own
but sometimes it's tough to get rid of
them
in such cases we can try different home
remedies like sipping a glass of cold
water continuously
swallowing a mouthful of honey or peanut
butter
holding our breath etc
now hiccups are completely normal if
they happen for a brief duration of time
but if you have persistent hiccups for
more than 48 hours
seeing a doctor is recommended
now did you know there exists a world
record for the longest duration of
hiccups
well this is your q box to explore
let us know your findings in the comment
section
and don't forget to subscribe to our
youtube channel
to stay updated bye